bourree two three four five six seven
and eight good okay let's try it again
from the beginning
my name is David kibble and I will be
doing ballet with my daughter close when
I found out that I was gonna have a girl
I was very excited she is my only girl I
have three boys so it's just like
completed the process for me it is
important for me to be here with my
daughter so I can show her how much I
love her and that I'm always gonna be
there for her no matter what even if
it's belly dancing
my dad can dance he have some moves that
are pretty hard for me to accomplish
pretty good my name is LaToya Bellamy I
am the artistic director and founder of
dancer for life la dance studio I've
been dancing for 32 years I started with
ballet of course I decided to open up a
dance studio when I turned 15 and
watching my teachers I was like oh I can
do this and within six months I became
the teacher the choreographer the
director of the class so growing up I
was like I want to do this myself and my
dance studio has been open for five
years I was blessed and now I am growing
and growing and excited to teach my
dancers ages 2 and up all right you
ready to do some ballet you supposed to
say yes I got tights on and everything
ok hi daughters and dads welcome to the
first day of
daddy daughter ballet you guys excited
awesome surrender some pleeease so
you're looking for a diamond between
your legs okay I'm gonna come up and
plie good and stretch I thought I
prepared myself and stretched a little
before but apparently you have to go a
little deeper gonna take out right leg
putting on top of the bar
dad's can go right behind them please
okay let's try it there you go good I go
right behind alley awesome if he pointed
there you go very good all the way over
good good stretch it out feel that
stretch there you go I was just making
sure the teacher went easy on as first
timers here we're gonna have a seat in
butterfly position please have a seat
what do you brother purposes meet
together
oh so daughters help your dad's out make
sure they're feeling the correct
position there we go up and down yes
you're correct legs up and down awesome
I stretch all the way over into your
butterfly head down to your to Sarah
come on your left knee railing in front
make sure one hand on each side of that
leg I should've did some a few extra
stretches myself I needed help with that
left leg Oh
[Music]
no I felt I did pretty pretty okay I
have a new respect for all dancers all
right guys we're gonna go across here do
some jetties
yes sir I start with a Chasse so right
leg and you're gonna step together and
then step and then jump step jump jump
good area look at uncomfortable so they
feel a little bit weird
yep Jessie it's good Airbus I think the
jetties were a little difficult to begin
with and Jesse and Jesse Jesse Jesse
good arrest my favorite part was when we
did choreography
all right girls dad's drivers from
choreo all right I really liked what my
dad picked me up
it's glad that I was able to catch on to
the choreography standing on my toes was
difficult
I'm too tall you guys random format yes
all right let's do this
[Music]
you
you
how did I do any great I think my dad
did really great I think my dad did
amazing I think my dad did outstanding
you know what I enjoyed it I'm just glad
that I was able to catch on to the
choreography I would say to all the dads
out there get involved and enjoy your
daughters as much as you possibly can
while they're little girls
[Music]